ça suffit beaucoup d'espoir si on est
capable de organiser ceci ça veut dire
qu'on est capable de faire beaucoup de
choses
[Musique]
le
congophone et c'est important pour nous
donc de compétition c'est là aussi
montre que le Congo est capable donc
organiser des tels événements surtout
avec le les les les stades tous les
ouvrages qu'on a qu'on a eu à travers la
francophonie je pense que c'est
important et ça ramène aussi la
fraternité entre des pays francophones
et surtout nous-mêmes aussi au Congo
malgré tout ce qui se passe mais le
Congo ici quand même un défi et moi je
pense c'est important
[Musique]
c'est que ce qui est plus important avec
la francophonie c'est que on bénéficie
de l'infarctus sportifs c'est qu'on
n'avait pas et ça c'est important je
pense que ça va aider plus pour la
jeunesse pour ça le message que je leur
lance c'est de s'entraîner c'est des
croix
pour nous maintenant nous avons
l'opportunité de venir enseigner éduquer
et apporter notre petite pierre à
l'édifice les sportif congolais